c'est un choix politique je dirais
idéologique qui fait que pour la
première fois pour une réforme des
retraites vous avez décidé de ne pas
mettre à contribution les entreprises
mais uniquement de faire porter l'effort
sur les sols salariés donc il faut pas
que la loi passe on est d'accord la
majorité je pense ici est d'accord non
il faut pas que ça passe non vous n'êtes
pas d'accord
l'augmentation de la durée de cotisation
de 42 à 43 ans qui l'a voté c'est vous
c'est moi en 2013 en 2013 au début du
quinquennat de François Hollande c'est
ça aussi la réalité de la réforme que
tous nous mettons en place il y a plus
de violences dans la rue là aujourd'hui
alors en tout cas il y a des mots qui
sont très forts et les mots ont un sens
notre collègue a dit quelque chose qui
sur le fond est juste puisque il parlait
des accidents du travail et donc il a
pointé la responsabilité du gouvernement
dans le fait que les accidents du
travail en France sont hausse constante
ces dernières années monsieur sain tout
la partie à cette formation politique
qui aura réussi un de force rendre le
gouvernement sympathique assassin
j'imaginais que ce pourrait être la une
ce matin du journal Libération
l'éditorial d'un journaliste de France
Inter j'imaginais Patrick Cohen le
directeur de conscience de notre
profession sortir de ses gonds
savez-vous que Jean Jaurès que vous
évoquez c'est fait casser la figure en
descendant de la tribu par des députés
de droite savez-vous qu'il y avait une
cellule de dégrisement parce que les
députés c'était surtout des hommes
buvaient et alcoolisés aller dans
l'hémicycle et sans activer et se
déclarer des duels à l'épée qui était
réglés plus loin en vérité en vérité
aujourd'hui les débats sont plus sereins
madame la ministre de très nombreuses
personnes ont été choquées par les
menaces que vous avez formulées à
l'encontre des chaînes C8 et cnews
en menaçant ces chaînes de ne pas
renouveler leur fréquence vous avez bien
sûr heurter les téléspectateurs qui
trouvent une autre manière de s'informer
bon il y a aussi des incidents
particuliers l'arabe du Vél' d'Hiv donc
ce sont des gens si vous voulez qu'on ne
pense les groupes musculaire qui sont
dans la provocation permanente la haine
permanente tu as jamais été question
d'un menacer telle ou telle chaîne ou
s'immiscer dans les pouvoirs de
régulateur qui est strictement
indépendant absolument indépendant merci
madame
de censure on n'a pas la même définition
de la semaine moi je les invite
aujourd'hui à se ressaisir ils ont il
est encore temps de débattre nous avons
nous sommes à la moitié du chemin nous
avons encore près de 35 heures de débat
et 14000 amendements à étudier d'ici
vendredi minuit on n'a pas l'intention
de retirer ces amendements parce qu'on
pense que c'est des débats qui doivent
avoir lieu dans l'hémicycle dans les
prochains jours et que ce sont des
débats importants et qui intéresse les
Français et les Français hier soir la
nuit pèse qui a déposé le plus grand
nombre d'amendements sur ce texte a fait
un geste qu'elle n'exclut pas ce matin
de renouveler nous en avons retirer 1030
lundi nous en avons retiré aussi
d'ailleurs vendredi il faudrait
quasiment 9000 à retirer lance un appel
à Madame panot c'est pas mis
l'amendement qu'il faut retirer mais
c'est bien 10 amendement donc je lui dis
c'est pas 1000 mais bien 10000 la
comédie a évidemment assez duré vous
rappelez un cadre légal mais ensuite
vous êtes là effectivement en menaçant
et je crois que ce qu'il faut faire
attention parce que si effectivement il
y a des chaînes de télévision qui ne
correspondent pas à la pensée unique à
la bienséance etc que vous voulez
imposer et bien il y a une réaction et
je finirai en paraphrasant un autre
rappeur Jul il dit personne ne veut
soulever des palettes tout le monde veut
sa retraite Pierre Palmade lui est
conscient les enquêteurs attendent
maintenant le feu vert des médecins pour
le placer en garde à vue et l'entendre
se pourrait être aujourd'hui ou demain
par ailleurs nous avons appris que la
maison du comédien situé à Cély-en-Bière
avait été victime d'une intrusion la
nuit dernière je ne crois pas qu'il y a
une tolérance sociale sociétale et
encore moins politique vis-à-vis de
telle ou tel drogue sous prétexte que
telle ou tel public le consomme plus
favorablement Nicky Hailey sera
candidate à la présidentielle américaine
de 2024 la républicaine l'a annoncé dans
une vidéo ses partisans l'ancienne
gouverneur de Caroline du Sud devient la
première candidate notable à défier
Donald Trump